if you're selling anything that is
significant if you're selling something
that's like high ticket you need to have
your angry pissed-off negative on our
social state you can't do anything well
your first customer is the most
difficult thing you'll ever do as a
business person wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how to
master the most important skills in life
enjoy okay let's kick it off with skill
number one give a damn with Dan lock
skill number one the ability to
emphasize with your customers you see if
you're selling low ticket item of you're
selling a commodity you're working a
retail shop people come in they grab and
go and always selling something that's
like transactional they just show them
the aisle or you show them stuff well
you don't really need to have empathy
because you're just providing a quick
answer a quick solution however if
you're selling anything that is
significant if you're selling something
that's like high ticket
you need to have deep empathy one thing
I always say is this we don't care how
much you know until they know how much
you care when you are selling something
and a higher price and a higher
transactional value your customers need
to know that you've got their back and
you have to be able to connect
people you know what if you want one big
secret when it comes to having
tremendous success when it comes to
closing here's one give a damn actually
give a damn about the well-being of your
customers give a damn about the result
give a damn about their outcome when you
give a damn if your product or service
are not a good fit you're gonna tell
them it's not a good fit if there's
other people there are the people that
could provide a better service better
than you you will not hesitate to
recommend that to your prospect that is
what I'm talking about
giving a damn and was doing a roleplay
with one of my students during one of
our live classes right we were doing
roleplay and he was saying all the right
thing he was asking the right questions
and and kind of following the formula
right saying the right words but I said
you know what you're not gonna close and
it's like oh how come I'm saying all the
right thing I'm falling the formula I
said I don't feel like you give a damn I
don't feel like you care there's no
empathy
you're like a robot all your answers and
questions are so mechanical in and so
robotic I don't feel the connection I'm
not able to connect with you
if I don't connect I not don't through
that you care I'm not gonna buy and at
first he was puzzled he didn't quite get
us at do it again then they do it again
he do it again and do it again and then
finally after multiple times is that now
that's better now it comes across that
you actually care about their well-being
very very important to have the ability
great closers have the ability to
develop their deep connections with
their prospects skill number to manage
your state with Jordan Belfort angry
pissed-off negative Unruh social state
you can't do anything well you've got
one of those days for instance where
everything you're doing you're like I
can't believe I said that I can't
believe I did that I'm such a fool right
yeah that day we've all had that day
yeah next day similar situation you're
like wow you know that was me I did a
really great job right you're perfect so
one day you're brilliant next day same
situation you're brutal that's not
talent that's not ability that's the
state that you're in so the key to
success is not
a tad your vision but to be able to
manage the way you feel in the moment
now if you're a parent what's the most
resourceful state patience if you're a
businessman looking to make money on
Wall Street it's probably certainty yeah
more courage because fear is the worst
emotion of all for being a trader on
Wall Street so every business has
different states that you need to master
now in most businesses in matters of
wealth is straight three states that you
need to master feel the trigger and a
moment's notice and it's easy to do what
you learn now we're just going to teach
people okay and number one is certainty
to be certain about what you're doing
the second one is clarity to be clear
it's not to be overwhelmed with the
office will be overwhelmed and the third
is courage is to have a conviction to
know that you might not be right all the
time but you're gonna got to let fear
stop you because if there's one
distinction that between the wealthy
people of the world and the pulpit of
the world is that wealthy people act in
the face of fear while poor people run
away from favorite skill number three
rethink your sales pitch with Jordan
Peterson your first customer is the most
difficult thing you'll ever do as a
business person in my experience to find
someone who will actually pay you that
first time facing your mom yeah well
that's right that isn't a family dinner
that's an actual customer and the the
other problem that people face when
they're trying to sell a new product is
one of the reasons one of the ways that
people decide whether they're going to
buy something is whether or not a they
know anyone else who's already bought it
or B if there's other people in their
domain that are already using it and if
if your sales pitch is well know this is
new and revolutionary you think well
that's a wonderful sales pitch it is
like it is if you're talking to someone
who's entrepreneurial and risk-taking
and interest and interested in
revolutionary ideas but if you're
talking to a middle manager in a company
the last thing that person wants to hear
is well you could be a risk taker and
introduce this into your company the
person's thinking I don't want to put my
job and reputation on the line for your
product even if it is revolutionary in
part because if it succeeds I probably
won't be rewarded for its success so
when we were selling our or employee
selection software for example we ran it
we were academics or and so you know
there was lots of things we didn't know
about business and one of the things we
ran into which was so funny we talked to
the people who were doing the hiring and
they had a certain budget which was
usually lower than because they had
virtually no budget for hiring weirdly
enough so what we were charging for the
product which was still extremely modest
exceeded their budget said well look
you're gonna make a 250 fold return on
this that's that's the pessimistically
it's 50 realistically it's 250 and the
upper end was more like 500 so it's a
no-brainer to implement this it's like
well we're budgeted on the cost side
what do you mean well if we if we hire
more productive employees we won't be
rewarded for that
we'll just be punished for spending more
money on oh what's that I thought well
we can't even talk to you because I'm
trying to sell you something that will
benefit your company but for you as the
decision-maker there's nothing but risk
and implementing the new process yes
that just blew me away it's like oh I
see the hiring budget and the
productivity budget aren't associated
that's like a fatal impediment to to our
sales process also if you want to have
more confidence and self-love check out
my 254 series they're free the link to
join on the description below a kid like
you if you had to keep track of 7 days a
week 24 hours a day what you do that's a
problem with young people you're not
good at anything
oh I'm doing good no tell me the truth
you're not good at anything
I always did everything back has half
words you know I like to challenge
myself skill number four practice a lot
with Dan Pina if you're in sales make
three hundred cold calls a day three
hundred cold calls a day three hundred
cold calls a day correct
well it's still work yeah we got kids
doing it one question we've even got
some lazy Dutch kids doing it right now
just pick up the phone yeah yeah man I
mean for us for a Dutch kid twenty four
years old to make twenty cold calls a
day you think it's a big deal
there's nobody's teaching sales in this
country that I'm aware of that tells you
to make 300 cold calls a day
in fact there's nobody on the planet
that I'm aware of that tells you to make
300 phone calls a day I had a guy just
do a 50 million dollar deal he said Dan
if you just told me I was 2,000 cold
calls away from my first deal I would
have sent you a check for 20 grand and
said thank you and I want to come to the
castle still number five don't play
games with Grant Cardone you need to
learn how to communicate with people
okay the the site here says the
PowerPoint says learn to become a
professional salesperson when I know
when I think of the professional
salesperson I think about a professional
communicator someone knows who knows how
to make contact someone who knows how to
control a conversation I don't think
about a swindler
I don't think about a tricky dude I
don't think about a huckster
I don't think about its scam artists I
think about dude this guy showed me
something I didn't know you have many
things now almost bought were the wrong
thing but a professional salesperson
with a full pipeline said no no no do
you don't want that when one of the best
salespeople I know okay guy named Robert
I'm not gonna give his last name because
I don't have permission I'm sure he
wouldn't mind 25 billion dollars where
the real estate hey Robert is this a
good deal yeah you know but that's not
the one I would do I would I would buy
this one over here if I were you okay
see see he's a professional he's a
communicator he'll tell me when I'm
doing wrong he'll tell me when I'm right
tell me when I'm wrong he'll challenge
me he's not playing games trying to like
match tones I saw this video the other
day matching people selling did you see
it okay right at the right moment at the
right moment lower your voice
and I don't want to do that I'm talking
about a professional salesperson it
doesn't have to rely on tricks because
their pipelines so big there's seven
billion people on the planet that are
qualified and interested in buying your
product you do not need to trick people
and that's what so many people think
commission I don't want to be a
salesperson equals I don't wanna be a
huckster well you don't have to be if
you're a professional and still number
six the last one before a very special
bonus clip
is master the skill of communication
with Robin Sharma most leaders most
businesspeople most entrepreneurs most
human beings have never learned to be
masterful communicators on the very
nature of influence and impact which is
the leaders job is communication I mean
in school were you given a communication
course very few people have been taught
that in your personal relationships have
you read books on communication well
that leads to I mean in in an intimate
relationship or even just with a friend
it's the little miscommunications that
over time stack into loss in your
intimate relationships it's the little
conversations that you could have had in
five minutes if you have the tools to
communicate and the awareness to speak
so literally you could release the anger
and build understanding and speak out
your needs and feel the need to be heard
all those little things if you had
learned how to do that over and done it
in five minutes with your intimate
partner you might not have lost the
relationship and in your professional
life learning to communicate inspires
your teammates you know if you look at
the great leaders of humanity the Nelson
Mandela is the mother Teresa for Martin
Luther King Junior's the john f
kennedy's if you look at the great
business builders Steve Jobs great
example right he would be on the stage
at the product launch and then that
favorite line one more thing and that's
when he would reveal the latest piece of
technology that would create industry
dominance when Steve Jobs was at Apple
well he was a masterful communicator and
Bud Tribble over at Apple called it his
reality distortion field Steve Jobs was
a master salesman he knew exactly what
to say to get people to believe in the
impossible to allow their I can't
to be less valuable than the right camp
now I've got a special bonus skill from
Mark Cuban on how to learn sales that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question the one how can you better
manage your state number two what do you
need to practice more and number three
where do you need to stop playing games
if you come up with an idea where you
say I can make dollar bills for 50
Cent's would you go out and raise money
or would you just go out and sell it you
just go out and do it you know and
that's what you have to do and look we
all go through that fear factor of do I
quit my job do I can I do this can I can
I do this and what happens next the one
thing I know with a hundred percent
certainty and what I would tell myself
is if I can sell and become a better and
better salesperson
and be great at selling I'm always going
to be successful whether I'm working for
myself or if the company that I started
just didn't work I'll give you an
example out of Indiana before I went
down to Dallas I needed to start
something and I decided that everybody
drank milk and I found this product
powdered milk that was cheaper and
everybody needed to save money and I was
going to go out there and sell it
because it was cheaper now it didn't
taste quite as good and so what I've but
I went out there to try to sell it
failed miserably but I learned how to
make the sales effort even when things
weren't going right I learned that the
rejection was every no got me closer to
a yes that not every product was perfect
but I could take those same skills even
in failure and translate them so that
what I learned selling garbage bags
door-to-door what I learned from selling
powdered milk that was awful what I
learned from selling local area networks
at micro solutions all those things
accumulated and I got better at selling
I always knew you know people always say
to me if you lost everything what would
you do I can sell I can sell when it's
not about selling ice to Eskimos it's
not about you know convincing people to
do this
selling is always about helping selling
is always about understanding the person
you're talking to and what their needs
are and if someone can help me make my
life easier yeah people you know now
with employees people always say well
like what's the definition of a great
employee someone who can reduce the
stress of those around them and it's the
same thing what's the definition of a
great salesperson someone who can reduce
the stress of their salespeople and if
in looking at your company and looking
at your life and looking at your goals
if you're able to go out there and
recognize that whether it works or
doesn't work you're putting yourself in
a position where you're helping somebody
not convincing somebody but and you're
reducing their stress you're gonna
you're gonna be okay it's gonna work out
and you know that's the confidence I've
built in myself that wasn't necessarily
always there um but I learned that if I
try to help if I reduce people's stress
good things can happen
if you want to know how to master the
skill of communication check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
never make a point without a story and
never tell a story without a point I'll
give you a couple of key things on
speaking for everybody